Okay, here's my favorite thing about this calendar
is it gives you little reminder.
So it says,
buy mom a damn card and a gift the Friday right before Mother's Day.
Actually, it's a fucking week before Mother's Day,
so it gives you time. And then it says,
call your mother. Love it.
That there's some days that are just
clearly halfway through the Fucking Week.
Like, there's just constant little reminders.
Same thing with Father's Day.
It says, buy your dad a fucking card
because it's gonna be Father's Day.
And it gives you, like,
all the funny reminders of things.
Pancake Day, Guacamole Day.
There's all kinds of funny little reminders of holidays.
Best part,
there's little stickers in the back for you to make it yourself.
Make your own little shit in the calendar.
Love it, love it,
love it. Let's see what it says for Christmas.
Look at Christmas lights, you festive bitch.
I love it. It's super funny.
I love it. It's linked here if you want one.